it is hard to believe but this is the
seaside of what should be a Tropical
Paradise in reality for millions of
people in Haiti it's a tropical
nightmare poverty unemployment crime
political chaos and a cholera outbreak
cast a shadow over the whole country
the coastal towns and cities are seen by
many as a gateway to a new life away
from this squalor and danger
they're dreamed of destination is the
United States and they'll get there by
any means legal or not
boats are becoming increasingly popular
for the desperate these are migrants
preparing to set sail
their sailboat will take over a hundred
people women and children are already
loaded below deck the Smugglers didn't
want them to be filmed
on Shore the next batch of men are
prepared by the captain for loading he
doesn't want to be identified he
successfully done this trip five times
but this time he plans to join his
clients and enter America via Florida
foreign
what are the people
that the people who you're taking are
they thinking exactly the same you what
reasons for leaving what are their
reasons for leaving are they exactly the
same of yours
memories
foreign
to the ship they've paid three thousand
dollars each to get on board in Haiti
that is an astronomical amount of money
the trip will take between three and
four days if the weather is good if it's
bad it can take eight
they will be sailing through the North
Atlantic with little food or water this
is desperate stuff but that is the point
they are desperate to leave
foreign
group comes across the harbor to join
the ship
there will be another stop on a nearby
Island to pick up more migrants before
the voyage proper gets underway
the point is they only have about a 50
chance of actually making it to the
United States the big problem they face
apart from the weather the days at Sea
is at the U.S Coast Guard is patrolling
along these Waters all the time and we
have seen
um ships like this being caught and
towed back uh to Haiti what they want to
do is just get into United States waters
then basically say we're here now and
they want to claim Asylum
all those on board helped the captain
set the sails and weigh the anchor this
boat will be absolutely packed before it
hits the Open Water of the Atlantic
they will try to evade the Coast Guard
if they're caught before U.S Waters they
will be returned to Haiti and they will
have lost everything
they're risking their lives and all
their money for the chance of getting to
the United States
and they all believe it's worth it
Stu Ramsey Sky News Haiti